intimacy between two human beings is
has the potential of being one of the
most
um
one of the
most evolved ways of being coming into
spirit and coming back home
the intimacy that occurs when two people
share awareness
when they have transcended the
boundaries of separateness for the
moment
whether it's through sexuality or
through the quality of trust and love
that develops until there is this
awareness that they both feel that they
are holding together they're they're
present in
and delighting in separateness and yet
the experience of unity is a
is a very highly treasured quality in
The Human Condition and it's
um
um it is a path to God
um
the
what it is that's being urine for
is the feeling that is the product of
the method that is what you're yearning
for is that feeling of being peaceful
being at home feeling warm feeling safe
Etc
the method of getting there
is the relationship
with another person
the relationship with another person
isn't the end point it's the process to
get to that state of ah yeah that you're
not feeling right
so often the attachment to the method
gets in the way
of realizing the real thing about what
the method was for which is to feel that
feeling of Peace in one's being and and
at homeless and safety and softness and
openness
the um the the kind of elaborate
the when you start to work with
Sexual Energy and relationship
the the delicate line between
um
where the sex is in the service of the
love or the Sexes and the service of the
increasing the Oneness
when it goes over the line into the
Greed for gratification or what's called
lust which is my need to use you to
satisfy me
in which the person becomes an object
which takes you away from the place
ultimately that you want to be
although see this is a
can you hear the complexity of it I mean
I'm playing with the edge of something
because what happens is you're using
when you use lust to get to God I mean
sexual lust with another person to get
to God you're using a method which
separates you in order for the moment of
transcendence when you transcend the
separateness but because of how you got
to there the minute the orgasm occurs
you're back in your separateness again
and you're back in a cruel way in an
interesting way I mean there is a
cruelty to lust as many of you recognize
I think
as opposed to sex that comes out of
equality of deep Attunement and Oneness
with another human being
um
and just why your last relationship came
unglued
which is because you
you couldn't transcend the objectness
that sex gave rise to the feeling of
in a way that your partner
was more attached to that gratification
to the well let's strike this for a
moment let's not go that direction
see the um the harsh answer the harsh
spiritual answer which we in the west
don't really aren't able to handle
because of our myths and our models and
the way we deal with personality
is Ramana maharshi's line about
about sexuality between people he says
what is it when two bodies rub together
what is it
and from that point of view people only
come together to procreate that's it
it's the only
reason from
an evolve sexuality and what's
interesting is you get to the point with
another human being
where you are so intimately with them in
Oneness
that to come down into a practice to
come to Oneness takes you away from
where you already are
it's interesting to be in love with
somebody so much
that the sexuality can be a play that
comes out of that Oneness but no longer
since it's previously been used as a
method to get you to the Oneness it's
like if you're in Detroit you don't have
to take a bus to Detroit
put crudely
that once the method that once you
understand where you're going with
another human being where you're going
into the space of Oneness you realize
that sex the foreplay and sexuality is a
method it is a method to bring you into
Unity into Union and it's an exquisitely
beautiful method and obviously it's a
profound method because it keeps the
species going
but we have overlaid it with a
tremendous psychodynamic
tremendously complex set of rules and
needs and gratifications and theory and
myth and so on so that most of the time
people are having sex in their heads
I mean they are really making love with
their own Fantasy Life which is part of
the horror of lust
so I I mean I haven't known how to quite
say it I've said make love only with
your friends
it's one of the ways I started to say it
I've
get to know somebody and open to them
through truth and trust and hold back on
the sexuality to the point where it's
irrelevant then you can
then you can have a ball
but when you need it you've got to watch
out that it doesn't come back and hit
you in the head
that's what I mean when I say crudely
screw your friends
you know I mean in Gross terms right
now
see after living with somebody where I
was absolutely delighted and thrilled
and loved the intimacy of it and fed on
it and it was a deep feeding for me
I also saw that that wasn't the path
that was suitable for me at this moment
and I saw why and I understood it and I
can't go in all the details but I
understood that and you can raise
questions about it but from my point of
view it was clear
and I am now living alone and when I
live alone there is
the there is loneliness that arises and
then when you go to bed it would be nice
to have somebody's warm feet to snuggle
with and so on and all that sort of
thing
and I I miss it but that's okay
that's okay because there is
um
there is a way in which the complexity
of that dance masks the deeper truth of
it
I would suggest I mean I guess I'm tough
in this I would suggest
that you allow yourself The Grieving and
allow yourself the sadness and allow
yourself the loss and allow yourself
that I don't have what I want
and grieve and cry and do what you need
to do until you can say okay and here I
am
until you can find the place in yourself
that can be at peace without having what
you want
then you are in the optimum position to
get what you want
because until then you're in need for it
is creating something in everybody you
meet
that is reducing the potential of that
relationship to be meeting a true being
of spirit in the right place can you
hear what I'm playing with
it's it's the statement in spirituality
again and again give up what you want
and you will get it but you can't say
okay I gave it up now I want it because
it's not clean enough it really is a
giving up and it's a giving up into
depth and friendship and you go through
a grief you go through a loss the grief
I'm not going to get what I want
and I'm going to be lonely and it's
going to hurt and here I am
I mean it's people that die before when
they die young or people that are sick
or people that are anything or people
whose child dies there is a grieving
process or when you lose a job or you
lose a dream there is a grieving process
we'll deal with that in illness group
sorry
don't cheat okay
sorry I took so much time with that one
because that's a one that's relevant to
a lot of us